[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books in more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug Bachelor president and
Speaker of amazing
facts Hello friends would you like to
hear an amazing fact about
mushrooms they're not fruits or
vegetables but we can find plenty of
these delicious fungus among us we enjoy
them in salads sandwiches gravy and
plenty of other ways mushrooms also have
several health benefits they're low in
calories fat-free cholesterol free
gluten-free and very low in sodium
additionally mushrooms provide important
vitamins minerals and nutrients
including selenium potassium riboflavin
niin vitamin D Vitamin B and some
Studies have shown that certain
mushrooms can help reduce the risk of
prostate and breast cancer science is
still exploring the many benefits of
good mushrooms but some mushrooms can
have a dark side of the thousands of
different kinds of mushrooms out there
about 20% are poisonous and 1% are
deadly if you're going to forage for
wild mushrooms you need to know what
you're doing because some of the Deadly
Ones can look very similar to the
healthy ones the consequences of eating
the wrong mushroom can range from a
little dizziness and hallucinations to
severe gastronomical problems and even
death one group of deadly white
mushrooms are aptly called destroying
Angels these incredibly toxic fungus are
very similar in appearance to the edible
Meadow mushrooms and they've often been
collected by mistake symptoms might take
5 to 24 hours to appear and include
vomiting convulsions diarrhea liver and
kidney failure that often ends with a
coma and then death you know the Bible
tells us that the devil is a master of
presenting poison teachings in an
appetizing way stay with us friends
we're going to learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers
[Music]
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at 1
1800 God says that's 1 1800
46372 97 now let's join our host Pastor
Doug Bachelor and our co-host Pastor
Jean Ross welcome listening friends you
heard the number and it is true there
are lines open if you want to call in
with your Bible question this is the
best time 800 God says that's 8 800 463
7297 800 463
7297 good chance your question will be
on tonight's broadcast if you give us a
call right now and for those who don't
know this is Bible answers live a live
International interactive Bible study
we'd like to invite you to join in my
name is Doug Bachelor my name is John
Ross good evening listening friends and
past the Doug let's begin the program
with prayer dear father we thank you for
the opportunity to study your word and
uh especially here on the air waves as
we open the scriptures Lord we pray that
you would bless our time together be
with those who are listening and guide
us to a clearer full understanding of
Bible truth before we ask this in jesus'
name amen amen well Pastor D open the
program by talking about mushrooms now I
happen to enjoy eating mushrooms but I
know there's many people that don't like
mushrooms they'll pick it off or out of
their salad off their sandwich whatever
the case might be but I guess there are
just such Variety in the mushroom
Kingdom of different flavors and kinds
and different health benefits as you
mentioned but you got to be careful
because uh what might look healthy might
not necessarily be healthy that's right
I was doing a little research in
preparing the amazing fact tonight and I
wanted to know how many different kinds
of mushrooms are there and there are so
many they say they haven't even numbered
them they know of at least
10,000 different varieties and there's
about a third that have not been named
or studied but they know that of those
the vast maor majority are safe but as
many as 20% are not good to eat some
just don't taste good they're not
dangerous but then there's some that uh
are deadly but they look almost
identical to some of the delicious ones
and U many people have died from
mushroom poisoning the problem is
because the symptoms don't appear for as
many as 24 hours they make no connection
between what they ate yesterday and all
of a sudden the terrible health problems
and so it's very difficult to diag no
since why people have to be careful
about picking and eating wild mushrooms
and it just made me think about how you
can have something that looks so
delicious and familiar but instead of
being delicious it's deadly and even
some of the deadly mushrooms when a
person eats them they taste great they
don't realize it at first you know and
the devil when he wants to poison people
with dangerous doctrines you know the
Bible says in 1 Timothy 4 there are
doctrines that are out there in the
Christian world called doctrines of
devils and if you're the devil and you
want to get someone to devour a deadly
Doctrine you make it look good and it
will be similar to the truth it's you
know whenever you want to poison someone
you mix the poison in with something
apparently or visibly good and uhu you
can read in 2 Corinthians 11: 13 for
there are false prophets out there
deceitful workers transforming
themselves into the Apostles of Christ
and no Marvel for Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of Light like
those deadly mushrooms that are called
destroying Angels Satan is a destroying
angel that can look like a good Angel
and um maybe you aren't sure what what
are some of those deadly doctrines that
Paul was talking about we have a free
offer we'd like to make available
tonight Pastor Ross is going to tell you
about it it is a book that we'll be
happy to S anybody who calls an ass the
book is called Satan confusing
counterfeits and as our free offer for
this evening just give us a call on our
resource phone line that number is 800
6747 and you can ask for the book called
Satan's confusing counterfeits that
number again is
6747 and the free offer Satan's
confusing counterfeits and if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800
46372 97 and with that we're ready to go
to our first caller this evening we have
uh Michael listening in Henderson
Kentucky yes how are you doing well how
can we help you tonight Michael Yes um I
was going to let you know that I'll be
watching your prophecy encounter series
very soon and I'm getting stud guys in
the mail sometime soon so I that's what
I'll be getting so I was want to let you
know that well thank you and you know
you just gave us an excellent
opportunity to explain to our listeners
that in what just a few days next Friday
evening we are going to be beginning a
brand new National Television evangelism
study it's a prophecy study called
prophecy encounter that we'll be
presenting live from the Orlando area
it's in Sanford Florida suburb of
Orlando and if people want more
information how they can watch that on
television cable Roku Youtube Facebook
just go to prophecy encounter.com
and Michael I'm glad you reminded us to
that was honest we did not pay Michael
friends to call in that question he just
did it on his own thanks for uh
mentioning that brother and we're glad
you're going to be tuning
in yes uh I have a question U uh my
question is uh uh what is the second
coming and why is it
important well I'm glad you asked for
one thing that is the opening
presentation next Friday another great
plug and we're going to be talking about
the second coming and signs of his
coming um of course the Lord comes for
everybody in a sense when they die
because their next conscious thought is
the resurrection and the Bible says the
Lord will descend from heaven with a
shout the voice of the Archangel the
Trump of God that's what 1 Thessalonians
chapter 4 and the dead in Christ will
rise and so when the righteous rise from
their graves they see the Lord coming
but there'll be some who are alive when
the Lord comes and and of course every
believer's always wanted to live and be
alive when Jesus comes and I frankly
think he's going to be I I was wondering
if you had a magazine uh called the day
of the Lord magazine by amazing facts
that you can send me we do have that
magazine and uh I I tell you what you
call we'll send you
one call the resource so Michael if you
call this number 8835 6747 and you ask
for you want to mention it specifically
the day of the Lord magazine we don't
often um give that one away but we'll we
today uh ask for the magazine the day of
the Lord and uh they'll be happy to send
that to you that number again is 800 835
6747 and they'll take your mailing
information all right our next caller is
um Franklin listening from Brooklyn New
York uh Franklin welcome to the
program hello Hi how are you
doing okay um yeah I want to ask
quick question and maybe another one if
I can get the time uh it says in the
Bible that Yeshua
descended now he descended as it says in
the Bible but the thief next to him he
told the thief next to him today you'll
be with me in Paradise so how could be
he descended into Hades and be with the
thief in Paradise in the same day all
right that's a good question first of
all people misunderstand the verse and
Pastor Ross will help me look it up when
you know the verse where it says that uh
Christ preached to those Spirits in
prison in was it second Peter um yeah he
descended Yeshua right well when that
happened it's not talking about Jesus
descending into a place of Torment it's
talking about the grave um Pastor Ross
yeah the verse you're looking at there
is um let me find it here it's 1 Peter
chapter 3: 19 matter of fact probably
need to start in verse 18 it says for
Christ also suffered once for sin and
the just for the unjust that he might
bring us to God being put to death in
the flesh but Made Alive by the Spirit
by whom also he went and preach to the
spirits in prison who formerly were
disobedient when Once the Divine
longsuffering waited in the days of Noah
while the ark was being prepared in
which few that is eight Souls were saved
through water that passor is 1 Peter
chapter 3 starting there in verse 18 and
19 yeah and so what uh what Jesus is
saying there Franklin is that um The
Same Spirit that raised
Christ uh went and preached to those who
were in prison of sin back in the days
of Noah now that refers to uh Genesis
chapter 6 when it says my spirit will
not always strive with men so during the
120 years when Noah was building the ark
God's spirit was striving with him and
the same spirit that raised Jesus was
preaching through Noah to the people
that back then who perished in the flood
it's not saying Jesus went to some uh
catacomb down on the earth somewhere and
talk to spirits to give them a second
chance and that's often been uh kind of
a strange interpretation that's been put
on that but um when it says you will not
leave his soul in hell it's not saying
that Jesus went to hell it the word held
there means grave or Hades uh in the Old
Testament it's
shol and it just means a grave Jesus was
not left in the Tomb and uh that's what
that's talking about there Franklin we
do have a few people standing by so I
appreciate your understanding we'll keep
it to one question tonight and uh so we
can get a few more if you don't mind
calling back we might get another
question in later thank you for your
call next call is Jean listening from
Clear Lake Wisconsin Jean welcome to the
program hello pastors my question
tonight is on Matthew 9:13 and Matthew
12:7 what it means about Desiring mercy
and not sacrifice Matthew
9113 let me read and Matthew 127 they
both say pretty much the same well
Matthew 9:13 says but I say to you that
Elijah has come and did whatever he
wished that's probably not the one
you're talking about is it no Matthew
9:13 you mean Matthew or Mark Matthew oh
I'm sorry Matthew 913 all right and uh
Matthew 12:7 yeah I desire Mercy not
sacrifice for I did not come to call the
righteous but Sinners to
repentance and and so what's your
question about that and in Matthew 12:7
it says about the same thing what it
means about Desiring mercy and not
sacrifice yeah and there's a there's a
place in the Old Testament where Saul
said you know I I I didn't uh Slaughter
the the sheep of the amalekites because
I brought them to sacrifice and and
Samuel says to obey is better than
sacrifice uh what God wants is it's not
a lamb that he wants he wants us to be
merciful it's not uh a killing lambs and
goats he wants us to be obedient and so
what the Lord is wanting is our hearts
is what it's saying and so if a person
thinks that I can make a gift to the
church you know we don't offer Lambs
today but some people say well I'm going
to make a donation a sacrifice but I'm
going to be mean to my family at home
well you don't God is not wanting your
money as much as he's wanting your heart
and being kind to your family and kind
and honest and obedient and I think this
is what Jesus is saying because the
scribes and the Pharisees they thought
it was all about you know I'm going to
fast and I'm going to give and I'm going
to say these long prayers and that means
God is going to hear me but then they
were stealing widow's houses and Jesus
no I want Mercy not
sacrifice okay that um so you believe
that's what the desire and mercy would
mean I yeah I you know they were upset
because Christ was preaching the if you
read the previous verse you read verse
10 it happened ases Jesus sat at the
table with the tax collectors and
sinners the Pharisees saw and they were
saying why does your teacher eat with
tax collectors he's going to be
unclean and um he'll be contaminated and
Jesus said look I want Mercy I want to
reach the Lost I'm not interested in you
know sacrificing lambs and then letting
your brother and sister die because they
don't sacrifice be what's being given up
by The
Sinner no the the Pharisees and the
scribes they put all of their um they
put a lot of stock into their works and
they would you know say long prayers and
they would make sacrifices and give big
offerings and blow the trumpet it was
all an outward religion I see and Jesus
saying I want to see the the law saved
and so that's the um I think that's the
main gist of what he's talking about I
hope that helps a little bit Jean and
appreciate your question our next call
is uh Gardner listening from Yonkers New
York um gardo welcome to the program
good evening uh I recently uh receiv
received a Bible study guide from your
ministry uh that I greatly appreciate
because it forces me to uh study topics
that I wouldn't probably normally study
in the Bible I would probably stay in
Prophecy I like prophecy but uh I was
surprised to uh read that there's going
to be Eternal consequences uh as far as
God's dietary laws I think the the Bible
uh guy would would to say that there
would be no place in heaven for people
people who eat swine is that true and
can you give me some uh I think it was
Isaiah
6617 could you give me any type of uh
further scriptures to to prove that yeah
well first of all I don't think the the
lesson I'm acquainted with a lesson that
I think we sent um we believe there's
going to be people in heaven that ate
pork now I think what Isaiah is talking
about is those who know
better that our uh you know God's people
had been given a pretty clear command
not to eat pork and yet they were hiding
behind the trees and doing it so that
was
Disobedience now I think you would agree
with me Garder that uh God does not want
us to have multiple
wives you agree sure okay but you know
there'll be people in heaven that had
multiple wives like King David and
Abraham and Jacob because God winked
their they didn't know back then in the
age they were in he winked at their
ignorance but we do know better and so
um when a person knows what the Bible
says whether it's regarding adultery or
whether it's regarding um dietary laws
in any area when someone knows what God
says and they deliberately disobey
that's serious so let me read the verse
for our listeners you and I know what it
says but I want to read Isaiah
66:17 it says for those who sanctify
themselves and purify themselves and
they go to the gardens talking about the
idol Gardens after an idol in the midst
eating swine's flesh and the Abomination
and the mouse will be consumed together
says the Lord so there were people who
said oh yeah I trust the Lord but in the
secretly they were worshiping idols and
they were eating swine's flesh you
notice it put swine flesh in the same
category as Mouse so hopefully people
out there aren't eating mouse Burgers
but the Bible also says pork's unclean
too yeah now you know we all know that
the Bible says um you know there's no
differ between Jew and Greek and male
and female but if there anything else
that you can give me that that would uh
solidify that that is still binding on
his uh New Testament Church yeah let's
talk about it uh some people think that
the health laws were just given to the
Jewish people but the distinction the
distinction that God made between clean
and unclean uh goes all the way back to
the time of Noah when Noah was on the
ark you know everyone sings the animals
come two by two but in reality the Bible
says the unclean animal
came on the Ark by two the clean animals
came on the Ark by sevens meaning there
were only two pigs on the ark so God was
making a distinction between clean and
unclean all the way back then no unclean
animal was to be sacrificed to the Lord
only things that have a clothing hoof
and they chew the cud and people were
never to eat anything that was unclean
the typically the unclean animals are
the Scavengers people are not supposed
to eat dog they're not supposed to eatat
Pig they're not supposed to eat vultures
and skunks and uh you know that's
usually the rule of thumb you know there
was a general Council that occurred in
Jerusalem uh when the gospel began to be
preached to the Gentiles and there was a
question that arose with the reference
to how many of the uh the Old Testament
laws that applied to Israel also applied
to the Christians and as a result of
this Council you read in Acts chapter 15
one of the things that um they recognize
is still been binding upon the Gentile
was dealing with diet uh it says but
write un them to abstain from things
polluted by Idols from sexual immorality
and things strangled and from blood now
this is talking about the uh the Gentile
Believers the Christians and right here
at the beginning of uh the Christian
Church there are regulations given from
scripture with reference to diet and one
of which is uh not to eat blood and we
know that's an Old Testament law
connected with the and the unclean
animals yeah and then Peter has that
Vision in Acts chap 10 and years after
Jesus has gone to heaven Peter says I
have never eaten anything common or
unclean and some people that think that
Vision means you can go ahead and eat
anything Peter says the vision means not
to call any man unclean and so he didn't
make any change in his diet and Peter
didn't take anything from that sheet as
some people say anyway and that's in
Acts chapter 10 so there's there are
plenty of New Testament uh references
also that our bodies are still the
Temple of the Holy Spirit and do not be
deceived God is Not mocked what you sow
you will reap God wants us to take care
of our bodies or we will reap
cholesterol and heart attacks you know
Pastor Doug we have a book that we don't
often give out but I I just like the
rhyming in the name it's called hogs and
other hazards it's a book we'll send it
out to anybody who calls and asks the
number to call is 800 835 6747 and you
can ask for the little book called hogs
and other hazards and we'll send it to
you and really just give some practical
biblical guidelines with reference to
living a healthy life again that number
is 800 835
6747 and ask for the book Hogs and other
hazards if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio is 800 463
7297 that's 800
46372 97 our next call is Mel listening
from Jersey City New Jersey uh Mel
welcome to the
program Mel you you there yes I
am and your question yeah you're on your
question
tonight uh I was trying to get some
information on Luke uh I've listened to
uh uh uh uh the mission the same uh
station that we're on now uh and uh they
were talking about Luke but Luke came
did Luke come on after Jesus died or was
he one of the original ones and he was a
Greek so I thought I just want some
information that you would have on on
Luke yeah good good question Luke of
course is one of the great writers of
the New Testament uh he probably was not
a Jew he was alive when Jesus was born
he was probably young he became a
traveling companion of the Apostle Paul
Luke was so thankful for the history
that Luke wrote with his education it
says he was a physician uh Luke wrote
the book of Acts and he also wrote the
Gospel of Luke and they actually are one
book they there I should say they're you
know one discourse written to someone by
the name of Theophilus so so lukee Luke
is giving a report to some wealthy uh
person in the Greek world named
Theophilus and he gives the Gospel of
Luke and then he gives the Acts of the
Apostles all the way up until just
before the death of of the Apostle Paul
it is a wonderful history and Luke is
probably my favorite gospel now we don't
know how Luke died there's you know
Legends but he was with Paul till the
end and um was one of the early leaders
Luke was not called an apostle but he
was one of the Elders of the church wow
well you've been most helpful and I
appreciate your station and and your
program well thank you so much Mel
appreciate your question and you know
we'll send you a free copy of the
amazing facts Bible study lesson if You'
like it it'll start you out on that
course yes the number to call is 800
83567 47 you can ask when they answer
the phone just to enroll you in the free
amazing facts Bible Study Guide Series
and that's for anyone the number to call
is 800 835 6747 ask to enroll in the
free Bible study series of amazing facts
our next Callie is uh Lynn listening
from um Brooklyn New York Lynn welcome
to the program hello hi you're on the
air oh Pastor Doug I appreciate you so
so so very much so very much I had a
thorn in my flesh for about 15 years and
then one Sunday I accident left my radio
on walked into the door and you was
answering the question you don't know
what a load you took off of my chest
well praise the Lord that's the word of
God but my question is concerning
members uh this fellowshiping members
from the church what is the
criteria I mean what's that all about
and how is treating them like a tax
collector is should would bring them
back in I think that would sh PA shun
them and throw them further back well I
I think when Jesus says and by the way
that's Matthew 18 I think it's verse 17
when he says if a person has been
misbehaving in some way they've accepted
Jesus they say they're a Believer but
then they start to live like the world
or they're doing something that is very
inconsistent with a Christian Life you
go to them oneon-one first if they don't
listen individually to appeal then you
maybe take one other person as a witness
it says if he refuses to hear the church
then you basically they're put off the
membership and you treat them as a tax
collector tax collector didn't mean
Internal Revenue it meant like the Lost
treat them like they're no longer a
member of the church um Tax Collectors
were considered the you know offscouring
of
society and so that's just what they're
saying is that if you are a member of a
church it means something and it stands
for something and um you know if a
person says I love Jesus and I follow
Jesus but they're persisting in some
form of sin and they're not repenting
and turning from that you appeal to them
but if they continue to rebel and to
follow their their course they'll end up
bringing reproach on the name of the
Lord and they you need to put them out
of the church and treat them like they
are no longer members that's what he
means when he says a tax collector the
publicans were just sort of out there
and
lost so I know that's difficult but uh
membership means something you'll notice
in Acts two when people were baptized
they were added to the church it means
somebody actually recorded them and
because they counted exactly how many
were baptized so someone was taking
notes and uh you know if someone
misbehaved they were
deducted you know the Catholics use a
big word called excommunicated and
that's sort of a Latin term but in
effect it means they're put out of the
church okay so hey I appreciate
appreciate your question Lynn and um you
know we do have a book that talks about
what it means to be part of the church
and it's called the bride of Christ how
do you identify the true church the
number to call for that is 800 83567 47
you can ask for the book actually the
study guide called the bride of Christ
the number again is 800 835
6747 ask for the study guide the bride
of Christ and if you have a Bible
question the phone line here is
8463 7296
you know we're going to take a break in
just a moment but uh before we go to our
midterm announcements want to remind
everybody that a very special program is
going to begin this Friday evening and
we're going to be uplinking a live
Evangelistic program 10art called
prophecy encounter from the Orlando
Florida area if you want more
information on that go right now
prophecy encounter.com we'll be back
with questions in a
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return in a
[Music]
moment I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to Big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
they're crisp clear and
enlightening get your today by calling
85387 75 or visit AF bookstore.com
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-Christian locations
in the world Beyond The Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
[Music]
motion the amazing facts Chinese
language website is now one of our most
visited websites we also translated
thousands of pieces of literature for
these nations what started out as
hundreds of followers is now in the
hundreds of thousands the impact of your
funds invested in sharing the
Everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the world word and none of
it could happen without your teamwork
with this ministry God bless
[Music]
you every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers
live we still have a few phone on lines
open if you have a Bible related
question call us at 1 1800 God says
that's 1 1800 463
7297 now let's join pastors Doug
Bachelor and Jean Ross for more Bible
answers
live we are back and ready to go to the
phones we do still have a couple of
lines open if you have a Bible question
this is Bible answers live the number
here you go 800-
46372 n 97 that'll bring you to Master
Control here in Sacramento California
but we're going out on hundreds of
stations around the country in Satellite
my name is Doug Bachelor my name is Jean
Ross and past the DG we ready to go
right back to the phone lines we have
Olivia who's listening in La Olivia
welcome to the
program hi hi thank you for waiting and
I appreciate your call you have a
question tonight yes my question is just
how do we know what God wants us to do
with our lives and how do we know that
what we're doing is God's me is like
God's will for us well the first thing
and Pastor Ross might help me find this
verse Jesus said If any man will do his
will it's the Gospel of John he will
know of the doctrine whether it be of
God so the first criteria in knowing the
will of God is being perfectly willing
to do the will of God and once we do
that you have that yeah that's John
chapter 7:1 17 If any man will do his
will will know and if you're willing to
do his will then the next things are you
wait patiently you look in the word of
God and God you know he wants all of us
the basics we all know God wants us to
come to Jesus to give our lives to him
to obey him as expressed you know to
start with the Ten Commandments and the
laws of love and um but he has you know
a different plan for each person now
there's a promise Olivia you'll find in
Jeremiah chapter uh 13 or 29 rather and
verse 11 Jeremiah 29:11 God says I know
the plans that I have for you to give
you a future and a hope God says he's
got good plans for each person and then
he says you'll search for me and you'll
find me when you search for me with all
your heart so Jesus said seek and you'll
find another way to know his well is to
seek to pray to wait and then do the
work that God has near you with all of
your might whatever is near at hand
don't say oh Lord you know I'm not going
to do anything until I can go you know
wind souls in some foreign Mission field
start working on your neighbor next door
and um then God will he'll make it clear
does that make
sense yes so just
like now I've got a book to God and just
keep yeah pray I've got a book I wrote
that is exactly on this subject Olivia
it's called how to know the will of God
and I will be happy to send you a free
copy it goes through I think 12 steps
Bible steps of how you can know the will
of God and um it talks about you know
prayer seeking getting Christian Council
waiting looking for providential
openings and there's about a dozen steps
there would you like a free copy of that
yes please thank you okay the number to
call is
8835 6747 you can ask for the book
called determining the will of God we'll
send that to you Olivia or anybody who
calls the number is 800 83567 47 our
next call is George and he's listening
from um here in California George
welcome to the
program thank you first of all I want to
commend you on your job that you're
doing well thank you we're just having a
we have a wonderful time doing it and uh
it's a
blessing my question is when Jesus comes
back the second
time I know he does not touch the Earth
and the uh righteous dead that are
buried will rise
first and then those which are righteous
living will be gathered
together but uh when he does come back
uh the uh evil ones are are destroyed by
his brightness
true yes and you can read about that is
that uh the wicked are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming
yeah and um we who are alive were caught
up to meet him in the air and that's in
1 Thessalonians chapter 4 and then if
you read in 1 Corinthians chapter 15
talks about in the moment in the
twinkling of an eye twinkle of an eye is
quicker than a
blink we're transformed and we go from
the ones who are alive we go from our
mortal bodies that we're wearing now and
God gives us Immortal glorified bodies
because you don't Flesh and Blood these
old bodies that we've got cannot inherit
the spiritual Realms of Heaven he's
going to give us a special spiritual
glorified body much better than this one
but the real bodies we still eat and
drink and run and do
things so is that's where it says the
the ones that are alive will be changed
at that's the moment when the Lord comes
after the resurrection we're caught up
to meet him in the air and somewhere
from the time that we're the word that's
where you get the word rapture we're
raptured up we're caught up we're
transformed and
we get these glorified bodies you know
we've got a study guide on the subject
of the second coming and a big part of
that study guide he's talking about what
happens when Jesus comes with reference
to the righteous those who are living
and caught up to meet Jesus in the air
and those who are resurrected when Jesus
comes and also what happens to the
wicked so I think you'd find that very
helpful it's got a lot of Bible verses
and uh some commonly asked questions in
the back and we'll send that to anybody
for free just call our resource phone
number it's 800 835
6747 and ask for the study guide on the
second coming called the ultimate
Deliverance yeah and one last verse
that'll I'm sorry go ahead George you're
still sinning yes if you're still
sinning when Jesus come back you'll be
lost if a person's living in
deliberate yeah if a person's living in
deliberate sin when the Lord comes they
will be lost you know I found another
verse for you on specifically on your
question and that's in 1 Corinthians
1551 it says for the trumpet will sound
the dead will be raised Incorruptible
and we shall be changed meaning we those
that are alive and so U that's when the
Mortal puts on immortality it's at the
coming of the Lord anyway uh we really
appreciate your uh call George and that
study guide Pastor Ross recommended will
also talk about the uh holy State we
need to have when Jesus comes one more
time the number is 800 835 6747 just
call call that number and ask for the
study guide on the second coming called
the ultimate deliverance and for your
Bible question the number to call is
7297 8004 6372
97 that'll get your Bible question here
to the studio and on the air our next
caller is Caroline listening from New
Jersey uh Caroline welcome to the
program good evening um I have a
question what is the difference between
the second coming and the Rapture oh
that's a great question um first of all
the word rapture it simply means uh
caught up now there are two principal
views on the second coming the old
traditional view which is what we
espouse here is that when the Lord comes
and we are caught up to meet him in the
air that uh it is not a secret that it's
very loud it's audible it's visible
visible it's Earth shaking that every
eye will see him and then more recently
in the last 800 years uh there was the
idea of the secret Rapture that was made
very popular through the books first by
how Lindsay and then by the series of
books that were done by Tim Le the Left
Behind series which of course was a
fiction series it believes the secret
Rapture that the Saints suddenly
disappear and life goes on for another
seven years during the tribulation
people who believe uh historically
believe that the tribulation happens
just before Jesus
comes and um that's why Paul said it is
through tribulation we enter the kingdom
of God so there's a time of trouble
before Christ comes and that's why Jesus
said he that endures to the end will be
saved endures this time of trouble so um
those are the two principal views we
here at this radio program we believe
the the historic view that uh
when the Lord comes there are not seven
more years for people during the
tribulation to repent and get another
chance that when the Lord comes and the
dead in Christ rise and we are caught up
to meet him in the air that is at the
end of this time of trouble so that's a
very short condensed study on that
Carolyn and we have that uh lesson that
Pastor Ross I think just told another
caller about that you would really
appreciate because it explains those two
theories Yes again the study guide is
called the ultimate deliverance and if
you'd call for that we'll be happy to
send it to you the number to call is 800
6747 and uh ask for the study guide
called the ultimate Deliverance you know
Pastor Doug amazing facts just recently
released a magazine dealing with the
second coming called the day of the Lord
now I don't think this is something we
can give for free but if uh anybody goes
to the website just amazingfacts.org you
can type in day of the Lord and you can
actually uh order one of those magazines
it's very in depth deals with a lot of
scripture dealing with the subject of
the second coming beautifully
Illustrated it's about probably 80 Pages
it's a big magazine great
resource all right our next caller
thanks for your call uh our next caller
is Ernest Jean listening from Detroit
Michigan Ernest Jee welcome to the
program Hi how are you doing well how
are you I'm
okay my question is is in Isaiah
54 verse 5 is for your creator will be
your husband the Lord heaven aim is his
name he is your Redeemer the Holy One of
Isa or is it Israel Israel yeah Israel
the god the God of all the Earth what do
that mean are they speaking of the Holy
Spirit well you know you can read in the
New
Testament um is it Ephesians Pastor Ros
says husbands love your wives even as
Christ loved the church and gave himself
for her throughout the Bible
God calls his church his bride right and
so this is one of the Old Testament
references to God saying I love you like
a husband loves his wife and I will
provide for you and I will protect you
you are my nation and every believer
it's not just for the church at large
every believer men and women can look to
the Lord as someone who loves us more
than a husband a good husband there's
some bad ones out there but loves he
loves do more than a good husband loves
his wife and would lay down his life for
her so actually he's not only talking
about the church he's also talking about
human an individual
relationship yeah but it's a spiritual
yeah an individual relationship so it's
a spiritual analogy that Jesus loves you
more than a good husband would love his
wife and it's not just for women it's
for men too you know I know it's harder
for men to relate to but um okay we are
the the church is the bride of Christ
not just the church at large but
individually he loves us that much and
when you get to Revelation it talks
about the church inside the New
Jerusalem coming down as a bride adorned
for her husband and then the book The
Bible Ends by God is inviting us to the
wedding supper of the Lamb first miracle
of Jesus was at a wedding to try and
teach that
message oh okay so now I I got it I kept
wondering wondering wondering when am I
going to figure this out I said well I
woke up and here's the answer well
praise the Lord I'm I'm glad that it
made sense and it is a beautiful truth
that U the lord loves us more than a
husband loves his wife you know we have
a study guide called the bride of Christ
and it deals with the subject of the
church and uh I think you'll really
enjoy this Ernest Jee just give us a
call on our resource phone number the
number is 800 835 5 6747 you can ask for
the study guide called the bride of
Christ again 800 835
6747 our next caller is uh Bob and he is
in College Place Washington Bob welcome
to the
program uh thank you oh I wanted to add
uh regarding the Rapture another good
book uh where that lady would be uh
anything but secret oh that's right
thank you very much yeah and so if that
caller who asked about I think it was
Carolyn asked about the um the Rapture
that uh book anything but secret you can
read that for free at the Amazing Facts
website appreciate that reminder Bob and
your question tonight I've read that
online I I had a question regarding um
the ministry about the Ten Commandments
being the ministry of death and then I
think that's in Romans and then in First
Corinthians it says that the strength of
sin is the law
yeah so what do you think that means I'm
just curious before I delve
in I'm not sure when was saying I was
telling them that we need to have the
law of God in our hearts and Minds that
Jesus quits it there but she was saying
well I don't want the streng strength of
sin in in my
heart yeah people misunderstand that and
obviously you know the elementary
question you need to ask when people
start talking that way is do you believe
God wants us to keep his law
I mean you look at all the verses where
Paul says the law is just and holy and
good and you look in Romans 2:3 Paul
said it's not the hearers of the law
that will be justified before God but
the doers of the law will be justified
when Paul says by the law is the
strength of sin he's simply saying that
the law shows us our sin the law is very
powerful in revealing our sin we are not
saved by the law but the law is an
important medicine
to help us need or recognize our need of
Christ it's the mirror that points us to
Jesus so there's nothing wrong with the
law just we're not saved by the law the
law is to inform us of our need of
salvation but anyone who says that they
think those verses mean I don't want to
think about the law because the law you
know is source of sin or it's something
bad oh no the law is just the law is
Holy the law is good and read Psalm 119
that's one of the most longest chapter
in the Bible but it's all about the
beauty of the
law and you know of sin just means that
it's that it shows
us yeah that well it exactly it reveals
yeah it defines it uh reveals it defines
what sin is so you know Paul goes on to
argue would have never known
covetousness unless the law said Thou
shalt not covet so um you know where
there is no law there is is no
transgression therefore there is no sin
so in that sense the Lord does reveal
sin but it's not a bad thing if somebody
is sick with a deadly disease and there
is a cure they need to know what the
disease is in order for them to seek out
the correct cure and that's really the
function of the law is to reveal our
sinful condition and then find Jesus
with the solution for He Is We are saved
by grace um through the work he does
so hey I app yeah I appreciate that you
know Bob we do have a study guide that
talks about does God's grace blot out
the law it's actually a booklet sermon
book and you can probably read that
online or we'll send it to anyone that
wants to better understand the
relationship of Grace and law very
important subject for people to
understand appreciate your call again
the number to call is 8835 6747 you can
ask for the book called does God's grace
blot out the law and we'll be happy to
send that to to anybody who calls and
asks our next caller is um Michael
listening in Florida Michael welcome to
the
program hi Pastor Doug Pastor Ross hi my
qu my question was um I guess in regard
to a um this the scripture uh I forgot
the reference but is when Jesus says
that no man knows the day nor the hour
of his coming and I just wanted to know
because you know from what I understand
um even from some stuff I've seen an
amazing facts that you know there's
certain key events that happen in uh
here on Earth uh before Christ's coming
um and the thing is I'm just wondering
when people uh sometimes like say on you
know just in discussion or you know
maybe um internet media would say that
oh this event that you know precedes
Jesus's coming will definitely happen in
this year like 2018 or 2017 or whatever
is that a form of date setting I'm not
sure if that's fair to say well if
they're talking about connecting the
date with the second coming yes it is
and that's inappropriate I think Pastor
Ross may have that verse yeah Matthew
chapter 25:3 Jesus said watch therefore
for you know neither the day nor the
hour in which the son of man comes and
then I think there's another
corresponding reference in Matthew 24 no
man knows that day or the hour day of
the yeah it so he nobody should be
setting dates for Christ's coming and uh
so far I think uh I can say 100% of the
people that have set dates have been
wrong so it's probably not a good
practice uh now doesn't mean we can't
know when there are signs that tell us
when it's near because Jesus actually
tells us when you see these things come
to pass know that it is near so he's
telling us to look for kind of some of
these General comprehensive signs that
tell us is coming is near but no no one
should set a date no man knows the day
or the hour right it was because it
wasn't exactly like um setting a date
for the actual you know Advent of Christ
but just like you know setting a I guess
like a date for the I don't know certain
key events that happen they set a date
for the close of Probation and and some
of those other things right yeah I I
think we need to avoid uh that you know
the bottom line is what difference will
that make if you if you believe the Lord
is coming in a month you're obviously
going to be really excited and try and
get ready but the Lord could come for
anyone listening to my voice right now
in 24 hours we don't know that right and
so why would we play with eternity and
wait like uh it's you know the day
before your taxes are due and then you
start doing your tax returns we want to
give ourselves a 100% to the Lord now
because no man does know the day or the
hour right hey appreciate your question
Michael that's a good one again I think
you'd enjoy reading the study guide on
the second coming called the ultimate
deliverance and we'll send that to you
or anyone might Michael who calls and
asks the number is 800 835
6747 next call is Franklin and he is
listening in uh Brooklyn New York
Franklin welcome
back hello yeah Franklin you're on the
air yeah you said I should call back if
I had another question because I I spoke
to you earlier we wanted to give you a
chance thanks for your
patience yeah um ham got the curse from
uh Noah
yeah right in Genesis cursed his uh son
and his uh
descendants and most of his descendants
got destroyed the Canaanites all the
ites they all got
destroyed but uh some of them went to
different places like Kush all these
places in
Africa is that why they all these
diseases and everything and uh the
people made each other slaves different
tribes invaded other tribes made them
slaves and all these things happen in
Africa is that why because of uh
descendants of ham no I don't think so I
I think that uh when Noah pronounced a
curse on him and uh Canaan it was
because um they had been disrespectful
Noah made the mistake of he was drinking
and he was kind of stumbling around
drunk and naked in his tent and uh ham
and his son came in and instead of
covering their father they made fun and
they went out and they told others about
it and because of the disrespect for
their father you know one commandment
says honor your father and mother God
plac a curse on uh on him and when it
talks about the descendants of him it's
not talking necessarily about blood
descendence but anybody who shows
disrespect for their
parents uh and you know you gossip and
and U say things about you know
revealing some of the embarrassing
things to put down your family that was
very disrespectful and whereas japheth
and Shem they went back and they covered
their father um and they showed respect
and he said there's a blessing on them
now through the course of history there
have been slaves of every race and so I
I don't think that you can say that that
curse uh had something to do with a lot
of slavery that uh fell upon certain
African races because the Canaanites
that the children of Israel fought with
were probably not the same group of
people that you find that inhabited a
lot of Africa uh so I think there was a
difference there at the Tower of Babel
long after the flood and the Ark
everybody sort of intermarried and
Scattered based upon who they could
understand it wasn't all based upon
their
ancestry appreciate your call Franklin
thank you our next call is Dan listening
from Zula Montana Dan welcome to the
program oh well thank you I was
surprised that I got through on the
number yep and how can we help you we'll
try and get a couple more calls in okay
uh my question is is in
Genesis um it says that God created Man
Out of the Dust and he breathed the
breath of life into him became a living
Soul okay so that breath is either
breath or or a spirit and I'm just
wondering is that Spirit the same as a
holy spirit or is
the Holy Spirit yolked up to that Spirit
yeah when it's talking about he breathed
into man and he became a living Soul the
uh the Hebrew word there is RO and it
means it's breath it's wind and you and
it doesn't necessarily mean the Holy
Spirit but you can be sure the Holy
Spirit came into him it's more talking
about the Breath of Life came into Adam
and he was animated by the power of
God's spirit uh and he became a living
soul that word
uh breath there and wind is used often
for interchangeable with the spirit
Through the Bible hey appreciate your
call we do have a um a study guide
called are the Dead really dead where it
talks about the breath and the spirit
and we'll send you a free copy of that
the number to call is 800 uh 835 6747
you can ask for the study guide called
are the Dead really dead we going to see
if we get another call on here this
evening we have Joe listening from Ohio
Joe welcome to the program
thank you I have a question on
adultery yeah yeah we've got just a
couple minutes joke and we make it
what's that now what does the Bible say
about committing adultery once a
Christian well you can read in uh
Matthew Chapter 5 Matthew chapter 19 and
of course the Ten
Commandments that you know Thou shalt
not commit adultery and you understand
that you know adultery which is a little
different than fornication fornication
can be uh any kind of impurity or sex
outside of marriage um adultery is when
the marriage vows have been violated
because one of the two parties or both
have made a marriage covenant and uh so
am I answering what you're
asking well I'm just wanting to know if
it is a forgivable sin oh yeah you know
the Bible says all manner well let's
look in the Bible King David committed
adultery and he prayed for forgiveness
and God forgave him you've got Samson
committed adultery and the last Act of
his life was being filled by the Holy
Spirit Hebrews 11 indicates Samson's
going to be in heaven so you've got um
you know and then King Solomon you've
got several people in the Bible that
fell in that area that were later
forgiven you get the woman at the well
in the New Testament and she had had
five husbands and she was living with a
man she wasn't married to so that would
qualify as same category of sin she was
forgiven what I don't what I don't
understand is the unforgivable sin how
can that how can that be how I mean I
don't believe I have committed it but
how could you commit it I mean now there
is a sin that is called the unpardonable
sin and uh it talks about that in the
Book of Matthew uh I have a book I've
written on that it's called Beyond Mercy
because we're running out of time let me
send you the book call the resource
number
6747 and tell them you'd like to get the
copy of the book on the unpardonable sin
it's called Beyond Mercy sorry to chase
you off the air like that Joe we just
you were getting chased by the clock for
our listening friends thank you so much
uh we do have a couple of important
exciting announcements be sure to tune
in this Friday to prophecy encounter if
you want to know about our national
Evangelistic program on Prophecy go to
prophecy encounter.com and you stay
tuned keep uh keep listening because God
willing will study his word with you
again next
week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith-based Ministry located in
Sacramento
California
Life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control Wham you're
hit with something new your marriage is
good Suddenly It's on the brink of
divorce the job's great and then it's
gone and so's your life
savings you feel healthy then your
doctor gives the bad news what's coming
next you could look to the stars but
they don't have the
answers but this does the prophecy Study
Bible by amazing facts this Bible's
special its 27 personal study guides
lead you on a life-changing journey
through God's word to discover real
answers to Life's questions from health
and relationships to family and the
future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible today
by calling 8538
7275 or visit AF bookstore.com
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation
bible.com is a free resource where you
can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's word go
deeper visit the amazing Bible timeline
at
bible.com if you'd like to enhance your
study of God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AFB bookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800 835
6747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible
[Music]
questions